[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  my mission is to empower people to  understand and enhance their health  well-being and personal development with  the support of user-centred and  personalized digital tools  [Music]  there are many challenges when we try to  understand how to design digital  supports for people most notably around  how you provide value through the right  information at the right time  meeting individuals needs and  preferences and importantly mitigating  any potential negative impacts  [Music]  i'm encouraged by all the women we see  leading the research and innovation  directives in europe and the value and  investment that we place on those  developments  [Music]  research needs more women and girls to  help it make better decisions  we represent nearly half of the world's  population but are not nearly  represented enough in shaping the  scientific developments that can change  our world for the better  [Applause]  [Music]